IT.
ONCE YOU GET, THERE IS A HALLWAY
HERE.
A HALLWAY HERE.
YOU'RE INSIDE THE COMPLEX.
>> YOU SAID THAT DAY, WE ARE NOT
LOSING THE U.S. CAPITOL.
>> WE ARE NOT LOSING THE U.S.
CAPITOL TODAY!
DO YOU HEAR ME!
>> YOU THINK THIS WAS THE THING
THAT WAS HOLDING EVERYTHING
TOGETHER.
>> I DID.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE ONLY
PLACE IN JEOPARDY OF BEING
BRAEXD.
LATER WE HEARD OVER THE RADIO
THAT THEY WERE INSIDE.
WE HEARD THERE WERE SHOTS FIRED.
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION IF WE
SHOULD JUST ABANDON THIS.
WE WERE AFRAID THAT PEOPLE WOULD
COME FROM BEHIND.
THAT WE WOULD BE FIGHTING ON TWO
FRONTS.
I TOLD EVERYBODY, I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE UPSTAIRS.
I KNEW THERE WERE THOUSANDS OUT
THERE AND THEY WANTED TO GET IN.
WE'RE NOT LETTING THEM IN.
IT SEEMED THEY WERE SOME OF THE
MOST VIOLENT PEOPLE IN THAT
CROWD, WERE RIGHT HERE.
IT ALL GOT CONCENTRATED RIGHT AT
THESE DOORS.
>> DID YOU THINK IF THEY CAME
AROUND, THEY WOULD SURROUND YOU
GUYS?
WERE YOU WORRIED ABOUT --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> BEING TRAPPED?
I SENT A COUPLE OFFICER TO THE
TOP TO GIVE US A LITTLE WARNING
SO WE COULD READJUST OUR PLAN.
SO THAT WAS DEFINITELY A BIG
FEAR.
>> SO IT WAS MOMENT TO MOMENT.
>> SECOND TO SECOND.
>> DID YOU EVER THINK AT ANY
MOMENT, OH, WE'VE LOST THIS.
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO --
>> THERE WERE A COUPLE TIMES
WHERE I DEFINITELY DOUBTED IT.
I'M TELLING YOU, WHAT GOT ME
THROUGH WAS I SAW OFFICERS I HAD
WORKED MAY WHOLE CAREER.
I TRUSTED, I WOULD SEE THEM,
LOCKIZE.
I KNEW IF THEY WERE THERE, IT
WOULD BE OKAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
PLACE WHEN YOU SEE AND YOU COME
INTO THE CAPITOL?
>> I MEAN, I DEFINITELY THINK
ABOUT THAT DAY, THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BUILDING, WHAT HAPPENS
HERE.
I STARTED MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAREER AS A U.S. CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICER BEFORE BECOMING D.C.
POLICE.
I HAVE A STRONG CONNECTION TO
THIS BUILDING.
I JUST BELIEVE IN AMERICA AND
WHAT THIS STANDS FOR.
>> THIS SEEMS SMALLER THAN HE
REMEMBERS.
TO YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY THE SAME.
I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME THAT I
CAME DOWN TO THE TUNNEL AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
IT WAS ACTUALLY THE DAY THAT I
WAS UP HERE WITH BRIAN
SICKNICK'S MOTHER, SANDRA GARZA,
HIS FIANCE, AND I REMEMBER I
CAME DOWN TO THE CRYPT AND THEN
WALKED DOWN TO THE LOWER WEST
HARRIS TUNNEL.
MAN, SO MUCH BIGGER THAN I
REMEMBER.
JUST VERY DIFFERENT.
WHEN I WAS IN THERE, ON JANUARY
6th, IT WAS LIKE A WAR ZONE.
LIKE, IT WAS JUST LITTERED WITH
WEAPONS, DEBRIS, CS GAS, L